Kürbis ich habe so Angst vor Kürbis
wirklich ja dabei
nein sag ich doch gar nicht
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt's ein richtig leckeres one
pot-gericht das heißt aus einem Topf ein
Eintopf heute gibt's was herbstlich
winterliches ich weiß es gibt nicht nur
Kürbis als Wintergemüse aber ich liebe
Kürbis mein Mann hast Kürbis und ich
weiß immer nicht was ich tun soll aber
ich habe mir gedacht heute gibt es mal
eine schupfnudelpfanne normalerweise
lieben wir Schupfnudeln einfach nur
angebraten und dann dazu Sauerkraut warm
gemacht und Apfelmus das ist so mein
lieblings schupfnudelrezept und togast
Version mit schmandgurken auch sehr
lecker ich glaube das ergänze ich ab
sofort zu meiner Favoritenliste aber
heute habe ich mir gedacht ich mache
eine schupfnudelpfanne mit Gemüse ihr
könnt jetzt hier Wintergemüse nehmen
alles was ihr möchtet auch gerne rote
Beete dazu geben und ein bisschen Kohl
was ihr wollt das ganze soll nicht
länger als eine halbe Stunde dauern ihr
könnt statt Schupfnudeln auch normale
Nudeln oder auch meinen Reis verwenden
also tobt euch aus in der Küche ich
zeige euch mal die Zutaten die ich jetzt
gerade da hatte und die ich einfach
jetzt dafür verwende dafür nehme ich
etwas Olivenöl eine rote Zwiebel und
eine Knoblauchzehe etwas Kürbis ich habe
jetzt hier den Hokkaido aber Butternut
geht auch 350 Gramm Champignons die sind
bereits geputzt 400 Gramm Schupfnudeln
dann habe ich hier Gemüsebrühe ich nehme
meine selbstgemachte gemüsebrühepaste
mit Wasser verdünnt etwas Tomatenmark
und Paprikamark Salz und Pfeffer hier
ein paar Gewürze ich habe frischen
Salbei aus dem Garten Oregano und
Thymian und dann noch zum Abschmecken
und verfeinern etwas Sahne und Parmesan
das war's und damit sitzt hier gut
vonstatten geht denn mir ist er auch
immer wichtig dass ihr beim Zubereiten
die bestmögliche
wie soll ich sagen Anleitung bekommt
dass sie einfach von den Abläufen her
alles so das alles gleichzeitig fertig
wird das heißt erstmal das was zuerst
gegart werden muss die Zwiebel einfach
schälen und in feine Würfel schneiden
oder auch mal einfach in Halbringe komme
ich schnell zum Halbringe
also halbieren und in Ringe
[Musik]
dann die Zwiebeln und Knoblauch
Scheiben mit Würfel sagen aber ich habe
heute keine Würfel es sind Zwiebel
Halbringe und Knoblauchscheiben die
werden jetzt schön angedünstet das ganze
mit Deckel aha aha da kommt ein
Schulkind
komm rein
dann kann ich schon mal den Kürbis
halbieren und etwa 300 Gramm davon
verwenden
und den Kürbis den Würfel ich jetzt in
feine Würfel ich habe eigentlich ein
würfelgerät warum wir wirklich nicht
damit egal jetzt habe ich schon anfangen
aber einfach feine Würfel und die
Zwiebeln immer mal umrühren damit sie
nicht anbrennen
dann kommen hier die Kürbiswürfel mit
dazu ich muss sagen das Ganze schmeckt
auch mit Butternut sehr gut oder mit
anderen Kürbissorten aber beim kürbis
schälen bin ich tatsächlich ein bisschen
faul deswegen nehme ich ganz gerne den
Hokkaido ich sagen den hockeredo Kürbis
weil man den mit Schale verzehren kann
und nicht extra schälen muss unsere
kürbis schälen ist schon
mühsam ja mache ich nicht gerne deswegen
spare ich mir das lieber brate ich den
Kürbis hiermit an ihr dürft das ganze
auch gerne gleich mit Weißwein ablöschen
statt Gemüsebrühe falls ihr das möchtet
ich nehme allerdings meine
selbstgemachte Gemüsebrühe die ist
nämlich der Hammer die habe ich immer
auf Vorrat die hält ewig im Kühlschrank
braucht da nichts machen die ist hammer
immer wenn ich Gemüsereste habe dann
packe ich alles in den Mixer mach
Gemüsebrühe draus das ist lecker
also hier bisschen anbraten
nebenher kann ich auch schon mal die
Champignons etwas in Scheiben schneiden
[Musik]
und wenn ihr jetzt merkt ist es fast
keine Flüssigkeit mehr da löscht ihr das
ganze mit Weißwein oder Gemüsebrühe ab
[Musik]
jetzt lösen sich auch wieder richtig
schön alle Geschmäcker die sich so am
Topfboden bisschen eingebrannt haben
also nicht eingebrannt aber ihr wisst
was man die Röstaromen die lösen sich
jetzt und dann habe ich es auch später
beim Putzen etwas einfacher mit dem Topf
und ich benutze immer gerne Gusseisen
Töpfe ich weiß es wird da immer wieder
dazu gefragt aber die sind wirklich für
alles wirklich für alles alles geeignet
weil sie den perfekten Geschmack haben
und einfach auch die Hitze optimal
verteilen gut speichern das Essen bleibt
lange warm ihr könnt den hat früher
ausschalten also eigentlich hat
Gusseisen wirklich nur Vorteile jetzt
kocht es hier schön auf ich gebe noch
das Paprikamark und Tomatenmark dazu
ich habe da immer so ein selbstgemachtes
aber da gibt es auch gute Alternativen
aber ich habe es nicht selber gemacht es
wurde mir mitgebracht aus der Türkei oh
meine gemüsebrüstaste fast vergessen
[Musik]
dann gebe ich auch schon mal die Gewürze
dazu schön Salbei aus dem Garten
Thymian Oregano und ich muss das Ganze
tatsächlich jetzt selbst erstmal
abschmecken denn bei mir ist so dass
Tomatenmark und Paprikamark schon stark
gewürzt sind
ansonsten gebt ihr jetzt Salz und
Pfeffer dazu ich probiere verschiedene
Videos
[Musik]
und das Tomatenmark
aber Pfeffer
[Musik]
ja hervorragend als ich das hier gerade
abgeschmeckt habe habe ich gemerkt der
Kürbis ist auch schon durch weil er eben
schön gewürfelt ist perfekt würde ich
mal sagen richtig schnelles Rezept das
bedeutet für mich die Schupfnudeln
können jetzt mit rein die sind ja schon
vorgegart
dann gerne auch Sahne dazu
das ist ein bisschen cremiger wird
mit stelle ich den Herd auf wirklich
niedrige Stufe
rein
und lass es jetzt hier auf etwas Stufe 4
so ein bisschen gar ziehen
und reibe währenddessen den Parmesan
dann bleibt immer noch genügend Zeit um
jetzt in den nächsten fünf Minuten
länger wird es hier nicht brauchen hier
aufzuräumen
Geschirr zu holen Tisch zu decken
Wahnsinn es war jetzt quasi ein Live
Kochen mit euch kann es sein mein
Echtzeit
ja
vielleicht können wir mal wieder ein
Live Kochen machen so das mal machen
dass ihr euch Rezepte aussucht die ihr
hier unter dem Video kommentiert und
dann können wir mal wieder live kochen
oder live Backen also ich weiß ja nicht
was ihr lieber haben wollt aber ich
finde so ein Live Kochen cooler weil man
es dann gleich verzehren kann wir können
uns zum Abendessen treffen also virtuell
treffen
wir kündigen vorher die Zutaten an
können dann cooles Frage Antwort Video
draus machen im Live kochen und dann
eben einfach schön einen Abend gemeinsam
verbringen kochen essen und wer keine
Lust hat mit zu kochen der kann einfach
Fragen stellen und mit schauen finde ich
cool schreibt mal gerne eure Meinung
dazu
unser 15 bis 20 Minuten Gerichte ist
fertig und jetzt ist auch gerade Murat
da zum Probieren ich würde sagen wir
machen aber eine Blindverkostung
weil es was komplett Neues ist ich habe
was komplett neues Problem ich bin
gerade unterwegs erstens ist die Ella
krank ja abgesehen und ich habe Besuch
da ja
Murat ist es eine Blindverkostung das
heißt entweder binde ich dir jetzt die
Augen zu oder du hältst dir die Augen
wirklich
aber ich bin schon was gesundes wer
sonst zu tun auch nicht gesund
okay ich probiere
okay nicht die Augen öffnen soll ich
noch Parmesan draufstreuen Parmesan ist
cool
die Augen bleiben schön zu ja
meine Kette wäre mir nicht verheiratet
ich habe so Angst vor Kürbis wirklich ja
dabei
nein sag ich doch gar nicht
heiß oder so heißt schon aber Fischer
gewohnt von mir
ab 18 ich Test sogar vor ob es heiß ist
und sag schön wonach es schmeckt und ob
es dir gut schmeckt
ja
es ist ein Pilz drin
und geschmeckt
gut
ich will nur dass du dich vergewissert
ob es wirklich gut schmeckt
und ja okay cool
auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10 10 ist das
beste sieben gut gell ja
voll essen
ja ich denke viele andere schon
wahrscheinlich nicht aber ja ich finde
es okay schmeckt gut
und ich habe mich gefragt was das ist
natürlich
ein bisschen Hackfleisch rein machen
können Hackfleisch noch drin hätte ganz
am Anfang mit anbraten da hätte das
nicht rausgeschmeckt
also
zwölf ja also für mich ist noch zwölf
und da dafür Murat dieses Rezept mit
sieben war ist es mit seinem Kottes
Kürbis also ich glaube hätte man das
ganze mit dem Augen verbinden nicht
gemacht hey das nicht gemerkt das war
dass ich was im Schild dafür deswegen
glaube ich probiere es einfach mal aus
[Musik]